There's a guy called Superman who can stop
soda yeah yeah and flies shoots lasers out
of his eyes yes he flies and he shoots lasers
out of his eyes yes no one said Superman that
might be a little on the nose you call yourself
Batman yeah I don't call myself super bad man
wait he's Batman what did you think we were
doing here I suppose the cousin's dinner he's
Bruce Wayne is Batman not really not So Much
Anymore you know they don't really need me
things have changed Gotham's now one of the
safest cities in the world I I need you we need
you in my timeline Batman's our strategist our
our leader the world needs Superman you're the
best detective in the world you're probably
the only person who can help me find him
so will you help us yeah I have to go
to work three minutes ago and sorry I'm
in sort of a rush for the sandwich
you can't rush a good sandwich dude
we have a situation at Gotham General
a robbery gone wrong this is the middle
of the morning why is our bat friend even
awake call Superman that was my first thought
ever about her I'm sorry is
my sandwich ready I learned
my lesson on the boat last year stuffed
my sister comes out with me she's drunk
personal comments about my mom's
friends as well which I think is
eating that candy bar maybe you could
throw it to me hi Bruce yes I'm coming
now is that fast enough for you
welcome back
everyone it's Charlie they dropped a whole bunch
of new Flash trailers so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel we're doing a
giveaway for tickets for the movie all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just post
your favorite moment from all the trailers
on the video the funny thing too is that even
though the movie is not officially coming out for
another week or so they've been doing so many fan
screenings if you're watching this video there's
a pretty good chance you've already seen the movie
so please don't post spoilers for the movie on
the video if you have seen it already but in the
first clip they just have a funny scene of Michael
Keaton's Batman learning about the existence of a
Superman and the Justice League for the first time
like what Superman he calls himself a super man
that's crazy which confirms that there was never
a Superman on Michael Keaton Batman's Earth before
Flashpoint like when he was just existing in his
own Universe there was never a Superman that was
never met a human's there was never aversed in the
Justice League now there were Batman 1989 Comics
that they did later on so if you really wanted to
find out what happened to those characters after
the events of Batman Returns they did actually
do comic book stuff for that I think part of the
idea is that they'll address some of that during
the movie like during this he talks about how
Gotham is now the safest city in the world in
his old age he's finally gotten rid of most of
the violent crime so Gotham basically doesn't need
him anymore which is why he essentially retires in
the flash comes to him with the younger version
of himself to try and bring him out of retirement
I love the way when they're initially meeting him
here like this is when they first meet him once he
finally tries to sell him on helping them he just
immediately says you know what pass obviously from
the rest of the trailers we know he eventually
winds up helping them though there's also a
longer version of this clip where he talks
about the timelines in Flashpoint using the
bowl of spaghetti with all the different strands
overlapping in the bowl the way they're treating
the concept of Flashpoint from the comics in the
movie is that basically the flash goes back in
time to try and save his mother does do that but
inadvertently breaks the timeline so to speak like
breaks the Multiverse so that a bunch of different
timelines start overlapping and the Earth that he
winds up crashing on here meeting his younger self
is the bull of spaghetti with a bunch of different
timelines overlapping in Michael Keaton's Batman
the main version of Flash from the Justice League
Earth Zod the other kryptonians and separately
Supergirl all of them came from completely
different universes and for a lot of the movie
it's this main flash trying to protect this new
timeline that he created on accident just because
his mother's still alive on it like I can't
believe I finally did she's still alive this is so
wonderful then like the comic book and the Justice
League Flashpoint movie coming to the realization
like oh wait no this should not be I have to allow
my mother to die like there's a fixed point
in time she has that I need to get back to my
original Earth and this new crossover reality
that he's accidentally created with all these
different timelines was never meant to exist it
just coming to peace with that idea like oh things
are going to go really badly here but this place
was never supposed to exist in the first place
the interesting thing about that original Batman
1989 movie though they did have an Easter egg for
the flash because they were trying to make a Flash
movie back in the 1980s right before they made the
Batman 1989 movie with Jeff lobe I talked about
this in a previous video he could never crack the
story like he could ever figure it out it really
didn't become a more cinematic thing like a more
movie-leaning kind of story until Jeff Johns came
and did the flashpoint story and they're like you
know what that actually make a pretty cool movie
story which obviously didn't happen until way way
later then once they figured that out there
were like 10 different versions of The Flash
movie with a bunch of different directors a bunch
of different actors until we're finally actually
seeing it hit the screens today in the way he's
learning about the Justice League for the first
time all these other metahuman characters
it sounds like there was never a version of
Wonder Woman or Aquaman or anybody else like Green
Lantern for instance but if you remember Alex Ross
actually released some concept art of the original
quote-unquote Justice League a version the Justice
League with all the big DC characters back in
the early 90s right after John Wesley's ship had
become a version of the TV flash so people were
thinking about them doing a Justice League story
with these older versions of the actors back in
the 90s but it just never came to fruition maybe
someday in like a big Multiverse movie they can
have some kind of Easter egg for that the other
interesting Easter egg is that when he's making
all these Superman jokes saying that I don't call
myself super Batman there was actually a super
Batman in the comics like that was actually a
real character it was part of a DC comic book
story like their version of what if Comics called
speeding bullets and it's the story of what if
Superman's pod crashed in Gotham on the Wayne's
property before they can see Bruce Wayne they wind
up being the ones to adopt alien baby Superman
raise him the way that they originally raised
Bruce Wayne even though now he never existed
they're eventually killed in Crime Alley giving
this new Superman character his origin story
becoming a version of Batman so he never becomes
Superman he just becomes a version of Batman with
all the powers of Superman so he's a little bit
more like the evil version of Superman like the
hardcore Superman and the Justice League Snyder
cut that winds up working with Darkseid because of
the anti-life equation except he's not evil he's
just very very dark like the 90s version of Batman
like imagine a Batman who's Invincible basically
think about how crazy how far he would go if he
knew he were Invincible even though Batman in the
comics right now without superpowers also acts
very cavalierly with his life like he acts like he
will never die that's one of the cool things about
the character it's kind of like Daredevil in the
Marvel Comics people that don't have super powers
but also aren't worried about killing themselves
so they just go way further way more hardcore than
other regular characters that would normally not
want to do something because they might wind up
dying there's been a lot of comic book jokes
about that where comic book Superman will joke
about why he likes Batman so much like IQs can't
wait to see what he's gonna do because he always
does such fantastic things even though he himself
is Superman the links that Batman goes to the way
he works around problems even though he doesn't
have superpowers are just so amazing to Superman
and the other thing you guys may remember if you
haven't watched that Batman 1989 movie in a while
is that when he's making fun of Superman for
calling himself a Superman there were jokes in
the Batman 1989 movie about Batman calling himself
a Batman fun fact too Robert wool who played Knox
in that movie also guest starred as his character
from earth89 during crisis on infinite Earths I
did a couple videos about this a couple years ago
when the episode actually aired but originally
they were going to try and use Michael Keaton
during crisis on infinite Earth but it sounds like
he turned them down they even made concept art of
him with the harness from Kingdom Come which they
wound up using for the Kevin Conroy older Batman
so it sounds like when they couldn't get Michael
Keaton Batman to come back for that they went to
Kevin Conroy and just changed the scene a little
bit so he was on a different earth the earth
he came from was meant to be a reference to
the Batman Beyond series because it was the same
year that Batman Beyond premiered and the other
funny Easter egg too is that when Michael Keaton
was negotiating to come back as the live-action
version of Batman it sounds like that was one of
the reasons why he didn't come back for crisis
on him for Earth because he was in the middle of
negotiating to come back for all these new movies
when that was still happening a couple years ago
they were actually developing a live-action Batman
Beyond movie for him like a more traditional Terry
McGinnis live-action Batman Beyond movie but when
James Gunn came on and rebooted the DC movies it
sounds like they either put that on the shelf or
just completely decided to not do it hopefully
someday we will see a live-action Batman Beyond
movie because he's actually still younger than
Bruce Wayne was during the events of that story
Michael Keaton is only about 71 years old in real
life during Batman Beyond Bruce Wayne is in his
80s so he could still age in to that much older
version of Batman so we saw plenty of time to
do live action Batman Beyond all the other Henry
Cavill Superman scenes in these trailers seem like
they come from before the flash creates Flashpoint
changing everything they had the funny scene of
him in the shop in Central City getting ready to
go to work trying to get his food like give me the
PB J because he needs so many calories but then
there's a bunch of Justice League problems all
over the Earth so all the different members of the
Justice League are handling things and they have
a funny moment with him trying to decide which
one to go help like which problem is the worst
should I go help Superman trying to stop this
volcano kind of seems like he has that Under
Wraps Batman calls him through Alfred needs him
in Gotham City they have a bunch of Wonder Woman
references in the movie too so pretty much all the
different Justice League characters are referenced
in some way once the movie comes out I'll do more
videos about the deleted scenes the alternate
endings because it did change a couple of times
once James Gunn took over just so the events of
the movie led into his DC reboot a little bit
more cleanly than they did before we do still
have the Aquaman 2 movie coming out later this
year there's also a lot of deleted scenes about
that because they shot a Michael Keaton Batman
post-credits scene then they decided to change it
and they brought Ben Affleck to shoot a version of
that post credit scene but then they also got rid
of that so there'll be all kinds of jokes about
how they change things multiple times in the last
six months or so for that movie for those of you
wondering too in this clip Henry Cavill Superman
isn't wearing the black suit he's actually
wearing his regular blue and red suit it's
just that the clip is kind of potato quality and
pixelated so it's really hard to make out the true
colors there's a bunch of other trailers and clips
that they've released for the movie so I might do
a couple more videos in the next week before
the movie comes out but my post-credit scene
video my full breakdown Easter eggs for the entire
movie and there is a lot not a lot of Easter eggs
in this movie won't post till after it actually
comes out so make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss any of that and do go
see the movie as soon as you get a chance there's
actually a pretty good chance that you can still
see it early because there's so many fan screens
happening early next week Marvel just released the
full opening scene from Secret Invasion episode
one click here to watch that and click here for
my brand new Blue Beetle trailer video and Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!